okay this is the solution to the problem
I posed in the last video you haven't
seen that video yet click here to go
watch it these questions about the
calculating the proportion of galaxies
in the observable universe that's moving
away from us faster than the speed of
light and to solve this we need a few
numbers so first of all this is a
diagram of the observable universe with
a radius of 46 billion light years we've
also got the cosmic expansion rate which
is 70 kilometers per second per
megaparsec so we're here in the earth
every mega parsec we go away cosmic
expansion rate increases by 70
kilometers per second and then we've got
the speed of light which we'll need so
step one is to work out what the radius
is where the galaxies are moving away
from us faster than light I'm not simply
finding how many of these mega parsecs
we need to go for the expansion rates to
equal the speed of light so this little
R is basically the speed of light
divided by the expansion rate and this
is in kilometers per second so this
actually needs to be 70,000 meters per
second because the speed of light in
meters per second okay so on my trusty
Casio that turns out to be around 4000
mega parsecs
[Music]
okay so that's the radius of little R
and now what we want to do is turn this
distance measure megaparsecs into
Lightyear so that we can compare it to
the big R which is the radius of the
observable universe so the conversion
rate is that one parsec is about equal
to three point two six light-years
plugging this into the calculator we
basically get 14,000 which will be not
14 thousand light-years but 14 thousand
mega lightyears that's 14 Giga
light-years 14 billion light-years
basically equals 14 billion light-years
okay so now we can compare 14 billion
light years to the 46 billion light
years and that will give us the
proportion of galaxies that are in this
region here where they're moving way
faster than the speed of light but we
can't just compare them directly because
these things aren't just areas they're
actually volumes so we've got the small
volume and then the large volume on the
outside so what we'll need is the
equation for the volume of a sphere
which you should remember from school
for over three hoops PI R cubed so now
we can just compare the ratio of the
little volume to the big volume so this
will be V little R against the bigger so
this is V little R this is the bigger
and we don't need to have the four over
three pi cuz they'll cancel out so all
we have here is 14
cubed divided by 46 cubed which equals
which equals zero point zero two eight
so if you multiply this by a hundred to
turn it into a percentage that's
actually like equals two point eight
percent so this is telling us that two
point eight percent of the galaxy is
within is not moving away from us faster
than light so that means one hundred
minus two point eight which is a is
roughly ninety seven percent so the
answer 97% of the galaxies in the
observable universe traveling away from
us faster than the speed of light quick
shout out to these people for giving it
a go and posting the answers in the
original video and yeah thanks for
watching let me know what you thought of
this video if it's a popular format I
might do some more all right bye